if I only worked out when I felt good
I'd be FF so there's a lot of days I
want to do it if no very punchy is you
in the face you don't really appreciate
safety because a lot of people don't
even understand what safety is some
people really love their life to sit
around and off when I sit around
I don't like me hello believe nation I'm
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all of the major problems
of the world so to help you on your
journey today we're going to learn from
commentator and podcast host Joe Rogan
and my take on his top ten rules for
success volume 2 rule number three is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best and as
always guys if you're watching if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below
put quotes around so other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick for yourself
as well enjoy
the one thing that discipline definitely
does help you with is it helps you get
things done and when you get things done
when you actually do things you you you
have more success if you have more
success sometimes a big part of success
is just not being lazy and just doing it
yeah just get it's like 90% of it is
just showing up get there and start
working like you're not going to feel
perfect every day if I felt if I only
worked out when I felt good I'd be upset
so there's a lot of things I want to do
it if it's pretty much the same with
everybody that if that actually gets
good at something that you you get
there's got to be those days you push
through and them they're probably going
to be more numerous than the days you
don't and so the benefit of discipline
in my eyes has always been that through
discipline I get things done I always
tell my say that I'm like the most lazy
disciplined person I know because I
don't want to do it yeah but I always do
write it down
yeah write down everything you want to
do I don't mean crazy like I'm going to
be the Prince of Brunei I'm another base
in the moon shut up this is what I want
you to do right write down what you
would like to fix about your life and
then just if you're 30 pounds overweight
you want to lose 30 pounds do it the
right way go start eating vegetables
monitor your calories write down what
you eat exercise every day force
yourself to do it say you're the general
the brain is the general the troops of
the body the troops I want to listen but
you go whew you listen and you get up
and you do it and then you get to write
it down and if you don't write it down
you don't eat you don't you don't you
don't shower write that down so you do
it it's like brushing your teeth it's
not something I want to brush my teeth
today what do you want you to eat the
run out of your head you dunce
just do it just do it make yourself do
it and if you do that if you write down
and do that you can change with you all
our bodies for whatever reason most
people their associations are to avoid
anything that's uncomfortable but it's
so illogical because when you look at
comfort and you look at success and
progress and eventual the feelings of
accomplishment and of getting past
certain hurdles and in terms of like how
you feel about life a lot of those are
connected to discomfort like discomfort
is your friend it really is like
discomfort and and not being happy and
content with certain situations in life
or certain feelings in life there are
massive massive motivators and there
they're amazing at facilitating change
and yet our instinct is to avoid those
and just sit on the couch and watch some
reality show about do to make moonshine
with our jaw open I groove it's with
bizarre there's a lot of artists and
comics I've bet means as well but we're
writers for sure one of the big problems
is sitting down and doing the work and
you've got an press field talks about
that it in the most concise and
beautiful way and he labels it like an
enemy calls it resistance you know and
that you have to sit down you have to
overcome resistance and that the pro
goes to work and it doesn't matter if
you're sick doesn't matter if you have
kids it doesn't matter what you you're a
pro and you go to work and that and that
just it puts it in your head that this
is what I do this is when you have pride
in that and then when you are in front
of that keyboard and you're you got you
look down the count it says a thousand
words today I put a sound more than you
yeah you you're doing the work and out
of that work gems blossom the little
things but you might have a day where
you just write nothing but dogs so what
show up again tomorrow and tomorrow that
dogs the flower will emerge you never
know and that's the only way to develop
real like to really develop your
potential 100% in anything if I look
back on anything I've ever done mistakes
I've ever made
paths that I you know what's something I
put out that I didn't quite maybe I just
waited three months for release fat or
maybe I should have you know re-edited
that blog post a couple more times for I
put it online or those things drive me
crazy with the things that I've done
have driven me crazy but yelling at
someone I didn't have to yell at them
for whatever but the most important
thing is always for all people to
recognize you
who you were a year ago you know who you
were five years ago you're not who you
were last week you're who you are now
this is the only you have control over
so you gotta regulate how much you dwell
on regrets of the past you really got to
be careful because it's good to have a
little because my regrets whether it's
things of professional nature or the
very few regrets friendship-wise which
is one thing that makes me very happy
but you know this there's life is
strange there's a lot going on there's
there's a lot of factors happen in life
but for sure Who I am now wouldn't have
ever happened if I didn't stop if I
didn't make those mistakes I wouldn't
have understand the importance of
friendship and kindness and if I hadn't
been cruel it's important my life or
someone hadn't been cruel to me I
wouldn't understand the beauty of love I
would have to I wouldn't understand the
full range of it because I hadn't felt
the sting if nobody ever punches you in
the face you don't really appreciate
safety because a lot of people don't
even understand what safety is you put
all we're safe were safe but you were so
not safe at any moment you know and when
someone's punched you in the face a
bunch of times and you've been in a
street fight with some guy you barely
knew you got an argument with there's
something about regular safety that's
sweeter yeah it's more delicious it's
more delicious it's it's way better to
drive your car straight after you almost
lost control on a turn when you get back
straight like whoa I'm not saying that
you should go sideways around corners
what I am saying is that there's a yin
and yang to this world man and you got
to fuel yourself with the cups and most
people get stuck in these patterns
because they define themselves as a cup
or they define themselves on the purse
who doesn't follow through on their
ideas or person who doesn't pursue the
real interests in loves you define
yourself by that well you know I guess
when I start things when I quit no you
don't know you have started things and
you quit and it gives you a horrible
sense of regret that's made you define
yourself by that you don't have to do
that you don't have to do that your life
would feel better and richer if you had
a goal you chase that goal you
accomplish some things you would get
this boost of confidence you get this
boost of self-esteem
like whatever it is you're going to do
maybe you're in a drawn comic books
maybe you're into nah by making pottery
or sculptures or but fine whatever that
is and pursue that instead of doing
nothing like the people that are doing
nothing
those are the real people look doing
something might be as simple as like
that Alex Honnold guy it climbs rocks
but he's world-class rock tomorrow it's
something I get to where I have to tell
people things that are true that are
even embarrassing about me now because
it's like it's so weird you can feel the
energy you guys won't run about that
efficient I mean you brought this up
elaborate on how strength is you know
this you get to talk hours a day in
front of people and then learn that it
becomes a real relationship well yeah it
definitely does and you know what else
is you goddamn you learn so much from
those people man you know even people
who are who are critical like they send
you a link to correct you like this is
the real information you have the
inaccurate information like if you don't
have an angle about all that if you
could deal with the fact that you might
be wrong or you might there might be you
might have jumped to a conclusion it
might be many possible scenarios you
look yeah you learned so much from
people on Twitter man you know a lot of
people will complain about like negative
things on Twitter I don't get that much
negative Twitter but I occasionally get
like yo map on your facebook do you [ __ ]
it you know well maybe it might not be
that like something from some of the
negative stuff like even if there's like
a ton of negative usually there's like
1% truth do it yeah yeah yeah and we'll
kind of stick in that back of your head
where you're like all right he took it
to like the next level but I do
understand that 1% of yeah yeah you can
get a hater who's like 90% hater but 10%
it has a point it does help you I really
believe it it's a terrible feeling that
feeling with some attaining on you but I
find it very beneficial because for two
reasons one because it's like snake
venom because like if you get bit by a
rattlesnake and you ever been bit by a
rattlesnake before it will queue up like
someone who has never been famous then
all sudden decides to do a reality show
and then they get all these insults
hurled
from every direction online that has got
to be horrific that's just going to be
torturous but when you take a little bit
of hate venom and a little bit of hate
venom then you develop an immunity to it
you kind of understand what it is
enjoyable well then it becomes a
checking mechanism and I look at it
almost like as if it's an algorithm and
I look at it like well this this
negative coming in like how much how
much does it affect me and how how how
much does it affect the positivity that
I put out like the DES is if I dwell on
it well then it'll surely me out but if
I just look at it if I truly look at
myself to say okay do they have a point
and if they do have a point if I am
being like I got a that's a very
important to be honest about that to
look at that I enjoy a lot of things and
when I found that the best way to live
my life for me I'm not saying you know
other people some people really love
their life to sit around and cough when
I sit around
I don't like me I like to get things
done but the things that I do the
Recreational they're all fun like Disney
was fun with my kids um Eddie Bravo
Invitational as far as the UFC was fun
as my show sold-out show at the car
theater where they do the Cirque du
Soleil at MGM and with Joey Diaz and Jim
Norton
Friday nights fun is it's fun to what
those are jobs right but those are fun
things and you know trans training is
fun the extent of comedy couldn't be any
fun or you know the only real work work
is like got to discipline myself to
sometimes work out what I don't want to
write when I don't want to but but but I
this is what this is how I feel it's
harder for me to not do what I'm
supposed to do than it is for me to do
what I'm supposed to do because if I
don't do what I'm supposed to do then I
deal with regret and doubt I don't I've
done it before I've done it a lot of my
life I've felt those feelings I don't
like it so what I do is I just don't do
that I just say well what is the
difference if I don't do it then I'm
gonna have to feel like I didn't do it
and feel like a loser so get after it we
were talking before this podcast about
Holly Holmes victory over Ronda Rousey
and one of the things we were talking
about was it Ronda
had this very linear straightforward
attack you knew she was coming and Holly
is a master at countering so all she had
to do was wait and move and Rhonda was
coming in one direction there was no
there was there was no variation no
create there was no creativity it was a
mad bulldog rush that had worked on
everybody else before but she found one
person who was a virtuoso at movement
and she needed creativity and it wasn't
there and she needed that experience
that came with having faced someone who
knew that position and nunu had a deep
understanding of that movement and she
didn't have that in their repertoire and
so that's the result that we saw like a
striker like Anderson Silva is extremely
creative if you watch she's got a fight
versus Tony frequent in Cage Warriors
Cage Warriors what was it called in
England small organization in England I
think you'd call it a Warriors have
where he practiced this step in upper
cut elbow like a sideways elbow and his
coach was going you're crazy stop
practicing that and he would make his
wife hold the pillow because his coach
didn't want him to practice it anymore
because he thought he was wasting his
time so he practiced stepping his wife
and hold a pillow for him and he'd step
in and throw this upper cut elbow that's
what he knocked out Franklin with and he
obviously fricken was outclassed in that
fight but he wanted to make a point and
the front kick that he landed the face
of Vitor Belfort Vitor never saw that
[ __ ] coming because nobody had done that
to him before because nobody had done
that in the history of the UFC nobody
had ever knocked anybody out with the
first kick you learn in martial arts but
the creativity to try something like
that he would throw punches to your
thigh from standing he would throw a jab
to your thigh he would throw a crescent
kick an inside Crescent kick to your
face like what the it was it was part of
what made him such an effective striker
is that he threw these things that you
just didn't expect him to do people who
are in jiu-jitsu
regular basis they're healthier people
there Eagles are healthier especially
men they're easy to talk to
they're easy to hang out though because
they're facing reality a regular basis
that something might I would note
teacher told me when I was a little kid
that I never forgot was that martial
arts are a vehicle for developing your
human potential and nothing in my life
has ever put me in place with reality
better than jiu-jitsu gonna pick you
know in like we can all distort our
perception of things in order to make
ourselves more comfortable in order to
make ourselves except where we are and
this lovely bubbler to learn around life
force you can't be close images when you
do jujitsu it's impossible to be
[ __ ] because reality funds that
you're in a purest form possible a life
or death struggle using your
determination your focus is techniques
your mind in your training or going to
remember them and it's reality and if
you up and you get caught a triangle
you've gotta tap that is an every story
it is real to get and that has made me a
better person it is making me a better
man maybe understand myself my
weaknesses my strength is 32 working on
jujitsu who has been one of the most
valuable tools of my life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed if you want to get your
pick of who I should profile next in the
top tens check out the link in the
description and go and cast your vote I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Jean friedlin Jean thinking so much for
picking up a copy of my books your one
word and posting that awesome picture on
Instagram I really appreciate the
support and I hope you're enjoying the
breeze so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
it's very rare that someone is
successful that doesn't have a crazy
schedule yes and if they are they're not
going to appreciate it they're gonna you
know like but it's it's all like what it
what is where you're at like is where
you're at where you want to be like are
you enjoying it because I'm what I'm
happy about the most is that I enjoy
what I do so when I'm doing like if I
was working as a CEO of some corporation
or something like that I was putting all
these crazy hours like the same kind of
hours I put it now same kind of effort
I'd probably be a miserable drunk
pill-popping psychopath who's just
looking to escape and go bang hookers or
something or some sort of a release